hi there Steve here's the Coffman back
in Palm Springs today I want to talk
about what makes a polyglot and you know
this term polyglot by the way if you
enjoy these videos about language
learning please subscribe
you know this term polyglot which we
hear a lot within the sort of community
of people who learn languages who get
together at polyglot conferences and so
forth
it's a term that a lot of English
speakers don't even use or many of them
don't even know and when I started into
this sort of the last 10 12 years of
active language learning I called myself
a linguist because in Inked people a
linguist is someone who is good at
languages in fact that's the definition
in the dictionary and the word polygon
has has grown in use recently its more
common in other languages but
nevertheless what makes a polyglot what
makes a linguist
and I think a big factor is luck okay
circumstance for example I arrived in
Palm Springs at the airport we I go to
over to look for my uber driver and
message comes back that the driver is on
his way his name is Abdul Wow
Abdul maybe maybe he speaks Arabic so
when I meet Abdul I say assalam alaikum
and of course he is an Arab speaker he's
from Sudan he's very happy we talked
have a lively discussion in the car that
kind of thing is motivating kind of
recharges my batteries not that I can
say very much to him if anything but
that kind of gets you going so other
examples of luck for example I was born
in Sweden so for the first five years of
my life I spoke Swedish and then I moved
to Canada and all of a sudden spoke
English and no longer spoke Swedish and
I can't even remember when that
transition took place
we spoke English at home but I've always
felt that that might have contributed to
me at least being interested in
languages and according to some theories
it makes them
more flexible and it makes it easier to
learn other languages so when I was at
the language long fest festival dalaran
language festival in Montreal and I was
giving a talk to a roomful of say 300
interested polyglots linguists language
learners I asked how many people in the
room were born in a monolingual family
like English or French speaking in the
case of Montreal just about everybody
raised their head so maybe being born in
Sweden to parents who were actually
German speaking mostly he spoke some
checked maybe all of that helped me but
all these people in the room whom I met
there he spoke eight ten twelve
languages they did not have that benefit
so something else triggered very
interested in languages interest in
languages but something there has to be
effectively as I've said before when I
was 17 years old I just spoke English I
had French at school I wasn't very
interested and then I had a professor at
McGill who turned me on to French
civilization French culture French
literature French history and
subsequently I went to France so that
was a luck something I could have had a
professor in Spanish or a professor in
you know law or something that would
have made me interested in that subject
so that was a circumstance that happened
you know and as a result of that then
again a friend told me that they were
there was a diplomatic you know an exam
to get into the Canadian Foreign Service
at the Embassy in Paris I wrote it I was
accepted that was luck again then the
Canadian Foreign Service decided they
needed someone to learn Chinese so I
started learning Chinese on my own and
then told them about it then they sent
me off to Hong Kong to learn Chinese
then I had a disagreement with the
person who was going to go to Beijing
with me and I said I'll go to Japan I
learned Japanese on my own but I don't
want to be in an isolated post like
Beijing with this person with it with
whom I have serious disagreement and
they said yes so then that was another
circumstance
made me learn japanese and i could go on
and on but the point is that there has
to be something that triggers that
interest because motivation is such a
big part of language learning and very
often that motivation is a matter of
chance there's a reason why some people
get interested in learning languages
other people get interested in designing
aircraft or becoming landscape gardeners
something triggers it and I should say
one more thing just to finish on this so
luck
I think circumstance luck is a trigger
and it's very important obviously you
also have to then put in the time and
and I think this is similar to a lot of
things in life I think people
underestimate the degree to which luck
determines it so much in life I can say
that in terms of my own business career
I know that it was more than anything
else
luck that determined whatever success I
had in business someone that I met
things that worked out that maybe
shouldn't have worked out but did work
out things that I couldn't have
anticipated which happened to me and I
think we have to always remember that
and that is why I think it is very
important in a society that we organize
our society in such a way that we
redistribute the opportunity that we
make it possible for some of those who
may have had less fortune that they or
maybe the next generation has access to
the same educational opportunities the
same health opportunities and and
therefore you know the fact that in many
countries of the world inequality is
increasing is not a good thing and it's
not a good thing for those societies and
it's not fair given the degree to which
income inequality is mostly a matter of
luck not a matter of some people work
hard now there's known it's largely a
matter of luck and so I just wanna I
just was thinking about you know luck is
a
factor yeah we can do things to increase
our opportunities we can do things to
increase the chance that luck will come
our way we have to take advantage of
things to come our way but the fact
remains that luck is a big factor and
that should force us to be a little
humble that's my message for today
thank you for listening bye for now